foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where debt is dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work they love actually be in
relationship with one another I'm John
deloney joined here by my good friend
George Campbell and we are taking your
calls on life money marriage
relationships mental health whatever is
going on in your life your work triple
eight eight two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five the call is free give us a buzz and
we look forward to talking with you
let's go to Kimberly in Charlotte North
Carolina what's up Kimberly how we doing
I'm doing good how about you fantastic
what's up
um so I have a question me and my
husband have just started watching Dave
Ramsey
um I am 26 my husband is 24. we make
about 105 000 a year before tax we are
debt free except for our house mortgage
and we want to start investing my
question is should we start investing
now or we're opening our health off
faster yeah
that's it the answer is yes and you're
going to do both in baby step four five
six we do them all at the same time so
you kind of get one plate spinning with
baby step four let's start investing
fifteen percent of our income into
retirement you guys don't have kids
no not yet okay so we're gonna fast pass
Disney style through baby step five for
now and go to baby step six so any extra
margin beyond that fifteen percent you
can now throw on top of your principal
mortgage
okay
um also we have
um an 80 000 truck that is paid off we
paid it off in a year and a half holy
Trump Batman
does it fly yeah
um it was my husband's dream truck he
got it before we got married and
then his dream truck turned into his
dream wife and now the dream truck has
got to go away yeah all right I that
putting that down on the house or
investing
this is me personally not owing owning
an 80 000 truck yes absolutely and our
advice when it comes to toys because
let's be honest an 80 000 truck is a toy
is not to have more than fifty percent
of your income tied up in things with
motors in them and it sounds like you
guys have as much income as you do toys
yes what is your car worth
uh my car is worth like uh six thousand
okay hold on what kind of drone man will
allow his wife to dry a drive a six
thousand dollar car while he drives an
eighty thousand dollar truck hold on let
me interject here Kimberly because
George drives a Tesla I'm just John this
is beyond Tesla at this point no I I
understand I come from a truck driving
State a place where trucks are equal to
if not a little bit more important than
the spouse I get it
um there it is
um yes there is a I I I I know of trucks
that cost eighty thousand dollars cost
110 000 that are tools they are they
have a utility to them Oh I thought
you're talking about the guys driving
them yeah
they have utility they're nice guys so
they are toys but they're also utility I
also know a whole bunch of dudes who are
a leveraged to their eyeballs to driving
80 000 truck when a used twenty thousand
dollar version of that truck will last
them for a long long long time and as
George mentioned
you guys don't make enough money to
justify having an eighty thousand dollar
depreciating asset in your driveway
I know especially I've been convinced of
it well it here's the the way to do it
this is not going to be a math problem
uh it might be it could be but this is a
I'm scared that we don't have an
emergency fund and you have an 80 000 oh
you do okay this is we do
um I want to be in a home
I want to start thinking now about what
our life is going to look like in five
years in 10 years and in five and ten
years you're going to have a forty
thousand dollar truck sitting in the
same spot in the driveway and we're
still not going to have a down payment
on a house
I'd love to see you sell that 80 000
truck while people still are still
paying crazy amounts of money for used
trucks and go buy a nice go buy a nice
thirty thousand dollar truck that's used
that's got mileage on it everybody's
gonna live and let's take fifty thousand
dollars and put that down on our house
what's left on your mortgage yeah
pardon me what's left on the mortgage
uh about two
oh well we actually just bought in
August it's like 2 20 I think okay
2015 years forget 15 years you guys you
guys have a life to live I don't want to
be in debt for 15 years do you
no so let's have a goal of five or seven
or ten at the most and what what is this
50k gonna do that goal it's going to
speed up that process by a lot yeah
definitely so think of it this way um
this has been a hank I grew up and we
didn't have a lot growing up and money
was a was a hard conversation and I
didn't know a lot of people with a lot
of money for a lot of my life and one of
the ways
um when I now get to sit by Dave every
week I get to sit by people who think
about wealth differently
and one of the things they have taught
me is to stop thinking about money
in ways a B and C or D how can I get
this thing how can I see this how can I
can make the shiny thing even shinier
and here's a a unique take on money how
can I buy hours of my life
how can I buy back time
and so if you just look at your hundred
and five thousand dollar household
income that y'all make and you think how
long would it take us
to put to pay down fifty thousand
dollars of our mortgage
that might be one or two or three years
of your life
and we can buy three years of our life
two years of our life if we just go sell
this big dump truck
and changing the way I look at my life
now I actually went and bought another
mower because it took me six hours to
mow my place out in the woods on a
Saturday now me and my son do it
together and we get done at two I just
bought four hours of my life back you
see what I'm saying so yeah that's how
I've started shifting
um how can I I I've started paying for
things that I don't normally pay for but
I started thinking how could I buy hours
of my life back and I want you to sit
down with him and say hey we could
accelerate this by two years by three
years and then we can get a jump start
on our debt-free life and bring a kid
into a world that doesn't know what a
mortgage even is and it starts with
selling your beloved baby out in the
driveway yeah
and we're all clear you get the nice car
next time right yeah
six thousand reason numbers 80 000. have
him call the show George and I want to
talk to him hey what color is the truck
I'm just curious what color is it
it is red I knew it John
oh my God I had it for two years and
it's brand new like he keeps that thing
as soon as you called in I was like big
white [ __ ] I was like this is a child
who grew up and got money and he wants a
big red [ __ ] hey and hey he doesn't have
a mortgage on it so high five to him but
man
that's a lot sell the truck man you know
what I'm gonna challenge him I'm gonna
challenge you to find a ten thousand
dollar truck to get you to and from whoa
put down seventy thousand dollars on
your house move this sucker dollar just
accelerate it man accelerate it buy back
moments of your life that'd be
incredible at 825-5225 give us a shout
on the Ramsey Show we'll be right back
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show triple eight
eight two five five two two five I'm
John deloney joined by my good friend
George camel let's go to Matthew in St
Louis Missouri what's up Matthew
hi
um everything's great my I went to see
the Chiefs last night and they won but
thank you for taking my call way to go
Chiefs uh Pat I'm a Patrick Mahomes fan
I like that guy so what's up yeah
um so God has called us I'm a pastor to
a new church in Alaska we're moving down
to Aleutian Islands everything's
provided we don't have to pass in our
furniture anything the issue is we have
a house the house is going to be sell
for
probably 200 000 you don't owe anything
on it
um and we're just trying the only thing
is it's by October 31st we need to
figure out what we're doing the next two
weeks if we keep the house say see if it
doesn't work out it'll cost us probably
about with insurance and everything
probably between 500 and 700 a month
whereas we could sell it for 200 000 and
just Bank the money and we'd have to pay
a little bit per month like maybe 50 to
100 for storage units but I'm just
driving back and I never thought I even
get on the Dave Ramsey Show so
um anyway so that's my uh dilemma do I
sell the house do I put do I have
friends watch it it'll be vacant but
that's not a problem where we live how
long are you thinking of of well I guess
you don't know why doesn't God ever call
people to Hawaii you guys got called to
Alaska that some just seems cold like
how long are you gonna be there do you
know
um well hopefully for a long long time
okay
um and we won't come back to this town
that's the other thing we're never
coming back never yeah so I like to yeah
I like to think of it this way if you
lived in Alaska would you buy real
estate to hang on to in this little town
that you're in right now the answer is
obviously no so I would sell it and get
out and if you have to I mean that's why
you have a realtor that if you end up
having to move before you sell it
um great does their job and they'll get
it sold for you I would challenge you to
put as few things as possible in storage
yes get rid of it sell it give it away
You're a pastor you know people who are
hurting and need in need of things get
rid of it man cut ties having a storage
space in a city five thousand miles away
from where you live is it just a recipe
never plan on visiting again exactly if
you get called to Hawaii or California
or Texas or something the worst part can
you imagine driving all the way to
wherever to have to get your couches and
your popcorn maker that you're still
never going to use you know what I mean
it just becomes such a waste such a
waste thank you so much for taking my
call and this will help because I'm
talking about with my wife back she
knows Nebraska but the whole idea of
selling it and if I say I have to talk
to Dave Ramsey's that'll uh because
that's what I was kind of thinking that
way but thank you all telling me talk to
Dave that'll help the conversation yes
not John George and I man when it's to
our benefit we say that we're Dave often
it helps a lot thank you very cool all
right let's go to uh Kia in Washington
DC what's up Kia
um so I'm 22 I recently graduated from
college with a degree in economics I'm
currently working in defense industry
making 65k annually uh right now I'm
putting since six percent of my income
into my 401K with an employer match of
5.5 I'm saving around twenty seven
hundred dollars a month until December
when I move out I'll be only saving
around 1600 a month right now I'm not
quite sure what to do with this money I
am saving I have about 16 000 already
saved in the high yield savings account
and seven thousand and an Investment
Portfolio so I'm just not sure if I
should increase my 401k or just
keep saving Kaya how did you get so
smart I'm just wondering for on behalf
of all 22 year olds
where did this come from
well I didn't
have like financial situation as a kid
so money when I was like 16 year old was
the main thing that I focused on and I
started working at 16 I've been saving
ever since you're incredible hey yeah
before you jump into this George
that don't lose that okay here that's
such a gift because it says to me that
you looked in the mirror at some point
and you said this stops with me
and you I I had the I had the uh
opportunity to go to college and I got
to watch my mom and dad they'd already
Blaze that trail I got to learn hard
lessons but people were had already
blazed those Trails ahead of me and you
had to go off in the Woods by yourself
and cut your own trails and so you're an
amazing young woman and please don't
lose that okay
thank you the world needs more of you
okay go ahead George so Kaya I'm
assuming you have such a great head on
your shoulders do you not have any debt
uh no I don't love it and you have an
emergency fund as well on top of the 16k
or is that included no that's including
the emergency fund okay so what do you
call three to six months of expenses
about 15K
yes okay so there's really not a ton of
wiggle room on top of your savings
you've basically gotten through baby
step three and now we're investing 15
percent of our income into retirement
and so I would up that six percent to
start can you get to 15 percent
yeah I can okay and is that a 401k
what's the retirement situation
oh yes it's before
I from years ago awesome is it do they
have a Roth 401k option
they do yeah awesome well you can go
ahead and invest all 15 into that Roth
401k and make it really simple
okay and then any money beyond that we
can start saving up for goals right now
you're just saving to save I want you to
have something you're aiming towards uh
so that you can be a little more excited
about it so do you want to be a
homeowner one day in your area
yeah okay so that would be my next goal
how can we start to save up 10 even 20
down on a home in my area and start
doing the math crunching the numbers and
figuring out how we're going to get
there
right
would that be your next goal you got a
good vehicle that's safe and reliable
question
that's great well you may want to save
up you know to replace that car in the
next few years as well so you can have
different goals you're saving towards
and just put it in ratios and say I'm
saving 15 to retirement I'm gonna put
500 bucks a month into a savings account
over here to upgrade the car and another
thousand a month towards the down
payment savings so that three years from
now I'm gonna have 36 000 for a down
payment
and so start setting those goals in
every area Ikea how old are you
22. okay
common challenge for 22 year olds who
are as driven and
um
um out of outside of the box as you are
is the tendency to you've been fighting
for a long time
you've been doing things on your own for
a long long time and now you've quote
unquote made it to this big goal you got
out of college you got your job you're
debt free
and now you're having to do something
you've never had to do before which is
to settle in
okay and so your next journey is not how
to survive not how to
um win with money you're doing that you
are going to be you're so far ahead of
the game it's unbelievable you will be a
multi-multi-millionaire and be able to
give and live like very few people you
know
your challenge over the next two to
three to four to five years is how can I
become comfortable in Kaya's skin
how can I just settle in and do really
really good work and then have really
great relationships outside of work how
can I laugh how can I go hang out with
friends you see what I'm saying this is
going to be your new skill set because
you are really really good at driving
driving
what we want to do like George said we
don't have a goal financially we won't
have a house we want to get a car we
want it to have a I don't know just some
arbitrary million dollar number in the
bank account whatever we also want to
have a life worth living
right we want to have people worth
laughing with and weeping with we want
to have people that can show up at 2 A.M
we want to have neighbors that we can
count on when the power goes out and the
power will always go out right so we
want to have these financial goals want
to have professional goals and we now
want to begin to build a life worth
living and this is just your new
adventure are you up for it
time to go on vacation that's awesome
vacation's so good you forget to
Instagram it now that is a cool goal
you just blew her mind that's I don't
think the 22 year old can understand
that John you did it
yes but I'm old that's true we'll be
right back
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
Rising learn how Christian Healthcare
Ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
welcome back America big news we are
celebrating the one year anniversary of
borrowed Futures launched by premiering
the documentary film on YouTube Monday
October 17th at 7 pm Central Time with a
watch party that's right borrowed future
is our award-winning documentary that
uncovers the dark side of the student
loan industry and we believe that every
single high schooler and parent of high
schoolers should watch this film so make
sure you share this with someone you
know that needs it you can follow the
watch party on October 17th and then you
can view borrowed future On Demand on
YouTube for free you're welcome America
up until that point it has been about
five bucks on our website on Amazon
Prime wherever you watch stuff Apple TV
Google Play and it's still available
there where you can rent it it ad free
and so if you want to watch it without
ads you can do it there if you want to
watch it with the ads you can do that on
YouTube zero cost to you so let's
continue to disrupt the toxic student
loan industry join us Monday night for
our borrowed future watch Party on
YouTube you can RSB RSVP there right now
for a reminder just go to our YouTube
channel hit RSVP we'll send you a
reminder I know John and I we're going
to throw a little party ourselves a
little popcorn absolutely
um when Monday rolls around I I usually
stop and think man I need to get in
front of YouTube and with the kids with
the kids yep and uh watching my dogs
by the time my dogs are old enough dog
College will exist couple things already
does
um and it's for puppies and I'm just
thinking back to my colleagues is to
work at universities and it wouldn't
surprise me if to give us a thing get an
email from somebody in admissions
University admissions just saying hey
could you house a
a a pet
um Mr Kamel is would like to enroll his
two pugs into the university they're
French Bulldogs give them the credit
they deserve what would they uh what
they have flat faces they ran into a
wall what like what would they study
George
um you know I think it would be culinary
arts
they're very food motivated
if you ever are driving down the road
and you think I think we're gonna be all
right just as a country we're not I'm
here to give you hope of the guys like
this well aside from that if you have
real actual humans in your house or you
plan to this is a must-watch documentary
and my friend doctor check it out he's
featured in it by the way and you have
some really great things to say they
edited around all the other stuff
perfect there's nothing like doing a two
or three hour interview and four and a
half minutes of it shows up but it's
good it's so good 88 minutes long it
will change the way you see college and
further education it will actually start
some conversations with your kids yes
and they'll be the one starting it going
wait mom is that true mom and dad that
this whole thing is like a scam and
they're like yes son absolutely well and
hey my friends who work in higher ed
um those and I I will defend them to the
end of the Earth are great people trying
to do the best they can trying to help
uh communities help young people help
people coming back I want to change
careers
watch this watch this documentary
because even if you disagree with it
um this is what people are feeling this
is the other side of the conversation
that I did not know existed when I lived
in this world and it has been an
eye-opening jarring conversation on the
other side of it so Monday October 17th
can't wait 7 P.M Monday October 17th
Central Time tune in go RSVP on our
YouTube channel and I will be watching
with you America very cool all right
let's go to Judd in San Antonio Texas
the most San Antonio name I can think of
what's up Judd
hey guys how you doing today good what's
up
hey so we just moved to San Antonio
actually from California and we are on
working on baby steps too and one of the
biggest things that we have in debt are
our vehicles
um one of them I'm upside down a couple
Grand the other one I'm actually wearing
a little bit of positive uh Equity right
now because of the way the market is
right now
my question is we have two kids and we
my wife and I both worked so we still
technically need two cars would it be
okay if I got rid of the more expensive
vehicle which would have the negative
equity on it and actually get a small
personal loan to cover that negative
equity
um
to lower the amount of debt that I have
or we have
that is an option it's it's not my
favorite option but it is an option the
best option is for you to find the money
and cover the difference in cash but it
is the only time we would tell you it's
okay to go into debt is to fix this
upside down car situation by getting a
personal loan from a credit union to
cover the difference and then we
aggressively pay down that smaller loan
that we now have so how far upside down
are you
um I haven't gotten an exact number from
a dealership but going to like Kelley
Blue Book or the other sites
um I would be anywhere from depending on
what they actually give me for the card
anywhere from two to six thousand
dollars okay put it on the Facebook
Marketplace today
try to cover the gap
if it's that close from a dealer I think
you can make a I think you can sell it
okay even if you come off even Steven if
you tell the person you're selling the
car to I'm just trying to pay this note
off so this is like I am walking away
here we are high five and I'm gonna walk
away with zero and you're gonna get a
good deal on a car
um
you're gonna sell that car this weekend
okay how much money do you guys have in
the bank right now
[Music]
so we're still trying to figure out our
budget like I said we just moved out
here our income has oh you just you just
moved from California to Texas it's
weird keeping all of your paycheck like
this right yes of all this money but if
you check your checking account right
now between checking and savings what's
in there
about fifteen hundred dollars okay okay
that helps me so the question is how
quickly can we get another 500 another
thousand dollars in the door so that we
don't have to take out a loan even if
there is a gap ideally you can just sell
it and you clear it
uh but if there is a gap you should be
able to cover that in cash pretty
quickly
sell stuff okay side hustles you name it
okay all right cool so what's your debit
card number George oh sweet let me make
sure to give that to you on air my
friend
you can do this judge you can you've
already made one good decision
moving and so now the next good decision
don't go into further don't go further I
still might consider selling the other
car if you can make a profit on it and
then just buying two cheaper cars
because you're still going to need a car
at the end of this
yes so what's the profit you could make
on that other car
um
uh pretty much about what I would need
to cover the other note
okay so you're saying a few grand
um it could be four or five thousand
okay because if you sell both you're
gonna have zero cars and so we have to
think about okay how can we scrape
together enough money so that when if we
sell both of these we can buy two
cheaper beater cars for now you know
I do just have a very small Roth IRA
which has about
forty five hundred dollars into it would
you recommend pulling from that to pay
off the balance Never full question of a
desperate man don't do it okay if you
had non-retirement funds like if they
were just in a taxable brokerage account
or some single stocks I would tell you
to cash those out but retirement and
you're going to face so many fees and
penalties and taxes it is not worth it
okay all right very good you can do this
man it's gonna take a little bit of work
and sacrifice but you know sometimes we
need to be humbled by driving the beater
car for a while and going yep that's
this is me acting my wage for now I have
been humbled for many many many many
years hey every time you hear someone do
their debt free scream on the show it's
because at some point they said I've had
it I'm not living like this anymore
and when you get mad like that and they
and then you do what they did your life
will change too and right now inflation
and your stupid credit cards and your
student loans and your car notes it's
killing you
you've been led to believe that you're
not in control of your money and that
that is wrong
you have to decide to control what you
can control and that's you the way you
think about things and what you do your
actions you have the power to change
your future and Financial Peace
University will show you how this court
will teach you the proven step-by-step
plan that's helped nearly 10 million
people beat debt Master budgeting and
build wealth and you can do it too we
had a great meeting last night George
with our new personality or friend Jade
paid off
a billion dollars sixty thousand dollars
four hundred and sixty thousand
you know what I love it I just wiping
the excuses off the table oh yeah I
don't tell me you can you owe 15 000
bucks you owe four hundred thousand
dollars the steps work the steps work
stop letting debt and money stress
control your life say I've had it and
take back your control start Financial
Peace University at ramsesolutions.com
FPU
ramseysolutions.com FPU
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
joined here by George Campbell let's go
out to Knoll in Newark New Jersey what
is up null
hey guys
um thanks for having me on the on the
show today uh I I've found myself in a
in a predicament I I'm following the
Ramsey program and and doing really well
with it I think
um as it stands now I should be
completely debt free by April
and um I I want to stay on track but
um a little bit of background of what's
going on is I
am a recovering alcoholic and you know
drug addict and been in recovery for 30
years will be April I got sober as a
teenager so
um
and but what's happened is the 12 steps
are kind of not doing it I'm opening the
door to more deeper issues things with
mother and measurement there's uh
intimacy anorexia which is not a really
sort of widely known uh topic but it's
something that requires professional
help and I'm seeking therapy with brain
spotting which is a version of EMDR and
all of these things are
um you know private pay you know
Insurance isn't going to to cover this
and I've done enough of them to know
that the answer is here and I need to
seek this uh more but there is no room
in my budget I mean
it's just there's no Road and so the
only option it looks like I have to do
is to put it on a credit card and
you know uh the therapy that I'm looking
to do is making me have to need to pay
like 900 to a thousand dollars more a
month than what I'm physically able to
to afford with my full-time job
so let me I'm gonna walk through this
backwards okay
um
uh my first statement is
um
I'm proud of you
what you've done over the last 30 years
is hard
Fair
yes sir cool
um and it's monotonous and it's every
single day and it's every single hour
and it's a beating and we often you know
like when you see somebody and you
haven't seen them in 15 months or in
three years and they've lost a lot of
weight and you're like oh my gosh you
look great and it happened to them every
minute of every choice of the thing they
didn't eat and every exercise they did
and
um for you you just see it all at once
and so I want to step back and just
applaud you it's hard what you're doing
that's incredible
um and good for you for having the
courage to go deeper right to actually
get to the root of some of these things
and you've been controlling behavior and
controlling thoughts for 30 years and
now you're ready to heal right
that's hard and I've man I've been down
the EMDR rabbit holes I had I sat
through a brain spotting session once
it's an incredible right it's amazing
stuff
um I would tell you a couple of things
number one if you have found a therapy
that you think is helpful and it's
leading you in the right direction
um choosing to not do that is not wise
okay
um and I think you've landed there and
I really challenge you I disagree with
your sentiment saying that this stuff is
forcing you to then make a decision that
is going to hurt you
which is putting this on a credit card
that's addiction language
I have to do this so that I have because
I have to do this and this is just the
predicament that's I call bullcrap on
that
okay is that fair
so we're gonna take just like we take
alcohol out of the house it can't be
here right I can't have it here we're
going to take debt out of the house
that isn't an option
so yeah what else is becomes an option
do I have to drive for Uber just to pay
for therapy then and let me be honest I
know what I'm telling you is nuts and I
want to tell you I've been there I've
got to do extra things so I can afford
the money so I can just go to counseling
okay I've had I've had to do that myself
am I going to drive Uber am I going to
take overtime am I going to stay late am
I going to let other things go that have
been a part of my healing Journey
because I need this medicine I need this
therapy right now
and here's what my promise is if you'll
put the time in and you will begin
you'll work out a plan with your
therapist on how we're going to make
this work financially and how we're
going to make this work
um in your life
it's little wins
and you're going to have some skin in
the game now
see what I'm saying you are going to be
taking above and beyond active approach
in your mental health and not just
mental health you're about healing this
is surgery right this is getting in deep
and getting out the infection that's
been there for a long long time you're
worth that extra effort but blaming this
on a shortcut that's going to end up
costing you down the road is just going
to Loop you back into another mess see
what I'm saying yeah yes and that's what
I was afraid of happening and you know I
I I've been like all right what would
Ramsay say which is basically the Ramsey
solution right and nothing came up so
the ability to come here and talk about
this I mean I'm also going to tell you
hey if you are if you are in true need
of
um what you're talking about for those
who don't know um enbr or brain Supply
you are talking about trauma healing and
you were talking about intense trauma
therapy for a short season
and so I'll tell you stop paying off
your debt and get healthy I wouldn't
tell you to forego Your Heart Care
Medicine to keep paying on baby step two
no dude don't die that's number one
right so let's get the trauma therapy
you need so stop paying on your debts
for right now pause for a minute and
take two three four months to get well I
also
um will challenge your therapist if
they're charging you 900 a month
different different therapy different
providers and you have to go to multiple
people and multiple things yes yeah okay
I would love for you to sit down with
somebody and see if you can coordinate
some of this care meaning it may be that
I'm going to do EMDR or brain spotting
on one once a month and I'm gonna go to
therapy on the other three would that
work
um I don't know the efficacy of what
your particular issues are and what your
particular needs are it may not work
that way but I want you to have that
conversation not just go okay and then
the next one okay and the next one okay
a part of my getting well I ended up
being a
um I'm gonna say a wisdom collector
I went to a counselor over here I met
with a coach over here my buddy was a
therapist so I always hang out with him
I had a medical doctor a friend of
and dude Purge everything I really I
needed to do the hard work
yeah you see what I'm saying yeah I know
I I've been called out on that okay
okay so same team
um I want you to take debt out of the
house and then sit down with your
therapist and be about
building a plan that works for you both
financially both psychologically and
both that works I mean and all together
works for your life and no I'm going to
give to you one year of Financial Peace
University as well as every dollar
premium our budgeting tool and because
what it comes down to is if you're 900
bucks short and you're saying my life
depends on getting this so that I can be
well then you're going to do whatever it
takes to find that 900 bucks and if that
means cutting subscriptions if that
means driving for Uber delivering
groceries dog sitting babysitting you
name it you're gonna do it and so that
budget will start to show you where your
options lie and where you can start
shaving expenses and what that extra 200
bucks a month could do for your budget
and I mean not eating out because we're
gonna meal plan so that we can afford
this level of care and so you're gonna
have to get really creative but that FPU
coupled with every dollar to really put
that plan on paper and you stick to it
because following that budget means you
can get the care you need
that is the best reason to budget I've
heard of today there you go and so we're
gonna gift that to you for one year to
help walk with you as you continue to
heal from this and hang on the line um
and we'll also gift you a copy of own
your past change your future it's my
gift to you and I want you to read that
book work through it and then highlight
the things that are important to you and
bring those to your counselor and they
become good good um places to start
right good good jumping off points to
talk about so thank you so much for your
bravery and golly you've been working
hard for a long long time
yeah that's a uh for people who have not
been in recovery for that long
um
it's just it's a lot it's it's so heavy
and it's so hard and it's so every day
there's that old thing
um you can never work out enough like
you can never have such a great workout
on Monday that you don't have to get up
and do something on Tuesday and
Wednesday right and I wish I could just
put it all on the line on Monday and
then be like all right that's my workout
for October I'm squared up it's not how
it works and man same thing with with
recovery it's minute by minute hour by
hour for a long daily battle that's
exactly right okay fine thanks to
everybody in the booth for running the
show even James Childs thank you so much
thank you George my co-host and thank
you America for listening to us we got
one hour in the books we will be back
shortly on the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
hey it's John deloney co-host of the
Ramsey show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the Ramsey show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studio
it's the Ramsay show where debt is dumb
cash king and the paid off Home Mortgage
has taken the place of the BMW as the
status symbol of choice on the Ramsay
show we help people build wealth through
work they love and create
relationships
it's the foundation we're so glad that
you're with us triple eight eight two
five five two two five calls toll-free
and that's about what the advice is
worth triple eight eight two five five
two two five I'm John deloney joined
here by George camel and we are taking
your calls on life work money mental
health all of it let's go to Michelle in
Cincinnati Ohio what's up Michelle
hi um thank you for taking my call of
course what's up
um so earlier this year my mom passed
away and
um I inherited an IRA for her
um now for my benefit
um and some silver bars and coins so I'm
really just trying to figure out
primarily what to do with the inherited
IRA
well what happened with your mom
the cancer oh gosh what was the duration
[Music]
um so at that point it went pretty fast
I'm George and I were just sitting here
both of us I could feel it in the room
um we both love our moms I'm sorry sorry
that's hard yeah yeah thank you for
trusting us with your call yeah yeah
well it sounds like she left a legacy
for you with a pile of money instead of
a pile of stress trying to figure out
the finance the financial part uh how
much was in the inherited IRA
um it's about 80 000. okay
and the silver and gold have you gotten
have you taken that to figure out how
much that's worth
I don't really know what to do with it
um I don't know if I should like
go to a jeweler or go to like a coin
you know cash in your coins but you know
people that buy silver and gold stuff I
would put it in a coffee can and bury it
in the backyard just in case it all
comes down Michelle
apocalypse happens
yeah exactly when people are struggling
for food and water you'll have a can of
gold bars
but that's what we need here yeah I
would definitely sell it I would start
with a jeweler and figure out
um you know what it's how much what the
weight is and all of that and figure out
where what it's worth and they may be
able to help you in selling that and
recommending some further options for
you how much how much gold and silver we
talking like three or four bars or do
you got a bag of it somewhere
bars and coins so okay you're gonna
probably not want to have your address
on the internet for the next few a few
months right
um yeah I would I would do that sooner
rather than later and I'd probably get
um if this is me I'd probably get two or
three different opinions
yeah of course um okay tell the Jeweler
who's gonna try to make you a deal
um thank you very very much and you'll
think about it and be back
yeah so where are you at where are you
at financially
um we are doing really well uh my
husband and I
um we just really have as far as the
only like liability would be his vehicle
uh we have a loan on his vehicle and
then our home okay do you guys have an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses
yes okay what's left on the car loan
um it's about 20 we ended up it kind of
like all have
just for like just get the loan and then
we actually were going to pay that off
in in a year so we already have a plan
we want to pay that off and just be done
with it what's your household income
that's not we don't want to touch any of
you know
any of any of the inheritance that that
I received if you don't want to touch it
what do you mean by are you like what to
do with it I don't I don't want to use
like planning with the inherited IRA or
like you know something for our kids so
this is a common thing that we do is we
attach
meaning
to gifts like this right yeah and we end
up when your mom tells you that right I
totally understood but you see you're
holding a seven percent car note on a
depreciating asset in one hand and then
you're holding gold bars on the other
hand you see what I'm saying and so it
becomes Downstream the greatest thing
you can do for your legacy if you will
is to stop oh and stop stop letting that
Legacy money make somebody else rich in
the meantime
yeah so you could have a fully funded
you can have this Ira you can have a bag
full of gold in the backyard and for
we're saving it to help somebody else
down the road and then at that same time
you're you're your money's walking out
the back door right
I know you don't want to hear that but
that's the reality the best Legacy you
can leave is is why you're alive and
that's getting completely debt free
while your kids are still young and you
have all of your income at your disposal
and now we can create amazing memories
and stresses and start funding college
and that's things we can't do when we
have payments hanging over our head and
so if you want here here's what it's
clear you want to not touch this for now
what if we sell the silver and gold
hopefully that's enough to cover the car
loan that would be cool and that puts
you guys at baby step four where you
have a fully funded emergency fund and
no Consumer Debt now we can begin
investing 15 to retirement and throwing
any future income extra margin at the
house and personally I mean you got the
10-year rule with the internet inherited
IRA so you have 10 years to use that
money
and that's what I just don't know what
to do with so you can I don't know
you're going to have to take it out at
some point and so we can't right but I
don't know it's like
put it in an investment account or add
it to our kids 529s or I don't know you
can do a little bit of everything you
can invest some of it you can save for
college with some of it and you can
throw some of it towards the house you
can take some of it and go on a vacation
it's a Choose Your Own Adventure at four
five six but you still have to be
intentional about making those things
happen you're investing 15 we've got
some put away for college we've got some
extra going towards the house and you
can do a little bit every year if you
want with the 10-year Rule and obviously
work with a Tax Advisor I assume this
was a traditional IRA so there will be
taxes on anything you withdraw
yeah okay so just work with the tax Pro
to figure out what is this going to mean
for our tax situation
um for next year if we withdraw any of
this money and it creates extra income
for us because it'll be taxed that
you're you're you know normal income tax
rate I I can speak to what I would do in
my house and I am
98.5 sure that I would take this and pay
my house off
I thought about that I would pay my
house off I would clear everything and
from this point forward every single
dollar that went into my house that came
into my home would be for what we wanted
to do with it I would be making nobody
else rich off my hard work from this
point forward and then I would save like
that for college and for down the road
and be I would be the driver's seat of
my own legacy at that point because I
would owe nobody anything that's just
what I would do if it was me I'm with
John or just two two guys opinion two
guys opinions who don't like owing
people money hey we'll be right back on
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the Ramsay show I'm John
deloney joined here by George Campbell
let's go out to will in Birmingham
what's up will how we doing
I'm just chilling on that how are you
doing today outstanding how can we help
so
as a bit of background
um I'm 17 years old about to go to
college and I am medically diagnosed
with autism and ADHD okay and my biggest
my biggest fear is being dependent on
the government or anyone else and I
guess my question is how can I go
through my life as a disabled person
without being reliant on somebody else
financially hmm
so tell number one don't ever refer to
yourself as disabled again cool
yes sir cool you have some unique
exceptionalities and you see the world
differently you're not neurotypical big
deal
okay yes Fair
so what
um
what what does your autistic diagnostic
what does autism prohibit you from doing
and what does it help you do
my autism mainly affects my behavior
I can't read social situations at all
okay and there are many times where it
affects my
employment okay
what are some things that your autism
provides you that are
put you ahead of the people around you
personally I feel that I'm very focused
on what needs to be focused on I can
pick out a situation and get it over
with pretty quickly several of my
favorite law students ever were high
functioning autistic
they were incredible and Brilliant and
struggled to with uh social cues
and so they went into more of business
law contract law where they spent a lot
of time writing and reading and thinking
through complex problems and then their
interaction with the world was largely
written right so that's just one tiny
sliver
I want you to not head into the next
stage of your life into college and have
you already been accepted you already
been on applying
uh no I'm not applying yet okay I don't
want you to head into this season with
your head down
okay okay I want you to head into the
season with your head up you've got some
challenges I want you to think of social
cues as skills
okay
sir those are some skills you're going
to learn and you're gonna you're going
to get an ABA program you're going to
meet with the college student support
services and they are going to
put you in contact with people that are
going to help you through your academic
Journey now the other thing what you
said I get with all my heart I don't
want
um
I don't want to be reliant on the
government I don't man how old are you
17. I I get that sentiment what I don't
like about that is none of us you me
George my wife my kids none of us get
through life without other people
walking alongside Us in supporting and
helping us
so I get you wanting to be autonomous
and I get you wanting to stand up on
your own two feet that idea is Noble
it's not reality for any of us okay
what I want you to do is have the
courage and the foresight to ask for
support and assistance when you need it
especially
academically and socially in college
okay
yes sir so I want you to think of asking
for support and asking for help as a
skill to practice because you've
probably either never done it you hadn't
had to because you you are smart enough
and driven enough to just get through
your assignments in in high school right
you can just buzz through that stuff
oh yeah okay college is gonna be hard
and some of that stuff's on a time
schedule some of that's working in
groups and you don't like working in
groups or your body reacts to working in
groups right
um and you get frustrated and then
people are like he's scaring all those
things skills okay and we're going to
reach out for support and help with
those skills is that fair
yep okay the world will be a better
place because you are in it
do you believe that
I tried to okay I don't lie and uh in
fact I don't lie to a fault sometimes
I'm telling you the truth okay now your
job moving forward is to take a
uncritical
head head up walking into the challenges
that lay before you not as someone who's
quote unquote behind the eight ball
already who's less than but somebody's
got different challenges than other
people do and I don't make light of it
you got significant challenges it's
going to be a different Road for you
than it was for me
and you are absolutely up to the
challenge do you believe that
yes sir excellent I'm proud of you well
what are some of your your talents
interests things you've been thinking
about pursuing or studying
um well I love to be a writer author or
something along those lines excellent
well that's something that doesn't
involve being around a ton of people all
the time and there's a lot of roles like
that and so George and I are writing
books right now and it's the loneliest
the loneliest thing in the world do you
want to write together no but there's a
ton of jobs I mean even you think about
computer programming and accounting and
you know auto mechanics and journalists
and the trades there's so many things
that you can do and so I just don't want
you to paint yourself in a corner and go
well who's going to hire a guy like me
right and what skills do I have dude
there's so much value you can bring to
your communities and so much impact you
can have regardless of where you're at
right now and can I tell you this will
um
now most of my day is taken up
doing podcasts YouTube and Social Media
stuff
none of those things existed when I was
17.
they didn't exist
and so what I don't want you to do is to
rehearse tragedy rehearse dismay
I don't want you to spend a lot of 17
year old 18 year old energy worrying
about things that may never come to pass
instead I want you to put your head up
walk into the challenges that are before
you and let those challenges consume
your day not imaginary challenges that
may or may not come down the road okay
okay and that is much harder than I just
said it I carry a journal with me
because I have a bad habit of that too
okay and I'm not on the Spectrum
is that cool
yes awesome I want you to
um hang on the line I'm going to uh
we're gonna send you a couple of things
to get you going we're going to send you
um Anthony O'Neill's book our good
friend Anthony O'Neill the debt-free
degree as you enter into the college
process we want you to do that debt free
and it's got a step-by-step guide there
I'm gonna send you a copy of on your
past change your future it's a step by
step here's how we're going to build
what comes next
um and uh we're also going to send you
um Financial Peace University for a year
I want you to start learning the skills
of budgeting learning the skills of
asking yourself what do I need and then
how am I going to get there moving
forward and this is going to um there's
gonna be nine videos I want you to watch
them I want you to pay attention and
internalize them and if your mom and dad
or your friends will watch it with you
that'd be fantastic as well but we're
going to give you several tools here to
get I'm going to do one more done okay
Ken Coleman's book from paycheck to
purpose love it that will help him
figure out what that next thing is that
he can sink his teeth into love it and
heading into college man here's what
I'll tell everybody
if you can learn to write
you can work anywhere right you can work
anywhere my dad used to tell me when I
was a little kid playing little league
if you can hit they will find a place on
the field for you they will figure out a
way to get you on there if you can hit
the ball uh to the it's writing now if
you can write whether it's social media
whether it's long form whether it's
short form whether it's expense reports
whether it is
you know
um you know
things that lawyers write doctor if you
can write
they will find a place for you if that
makes me feel better John I'm so glad we
moved from being able to hit a ball to
being able to write a sentence that's
something I can do we're getting there
George we're getting there
um George we are way way ahead um here
but tell us
um what are you thinking about writing
about well John as I've been here for
nine years and kind of been a part of
this journey battling against such toxic
myths that we believe is a culture that
have led us into this place I really
want to hit that head on and a lot of
stuff I did in fine print and we'll be
covered in borrowed future and showing
people to path out because I was that
guy who thought well this is normal and
I realized normal sucks and there's
another way to live and so I want to
unpack that system for people and go oh
my gosh I was believing a lie now I'm
outside of the Matrix now we can become
debt free and live life on our terms
instead of lenders terms and so that's a
that's a little bit of what I'm working
on but I'm excited about it love it love
it love it I can't wait to read it hey
this is the Ramsay show we'll be right
back
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site
churchillmortgage.com Ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
.com is 100 satisfaction guarantee means
even if you miss measure or pick the
wrong color they'll remake your blinds
for free you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promo codes
they run every month you'll save even
more use promo code Ramsey to get the
best deal today's question comes from
Lauren in New Mexico she says my husband
claims to be a air quotes Dave Ramsey
guy to his credit we are now debt free
with no mortgage but we are not on the
same page financially I do not know how
much money is in our accounts nor do I
know what accounts we have or how much
money he makes he is self-employed with
a few business ventures I currently do
not have a job as I oversee care for my
85 year old father and homeschool our
special needs daughter I can figure it
out all out by force but want him to
share and include me voluntarily do I
keep waiting for a calm and peaceful
inclusion in our finances or do I just
gather the information against his will
and move on Lauren that will never come
there will never be a moment he's
driving down the road and things to
himself whoa I'm an arrogant jerk who
uses
um Wheels I know something you don't
know as a form of power in my marriage
or
you know what I treat my wife like a
seven-year-old daughter
um
that's never gonna happen
it's not gonna happen
you're gonna have to sit down and say
not knowing our financial position not
knowing where the money is what you owe
what businesses you have
scares me to death
I can't breathe when I think about our
money because I don't know where it is I
don't know our I don't know anything
and if you die
I don't know what to do next
and if you live I don't know what to do
next and I'm watching my 85 year old dad
pass away in front of me I'm
homeschooling her special needs daughter
I am already exhausted both
psychologically and spiritually and like
physically
I need you to be on the same page with
me
that's where you start and here's the
scary thing about being vulnerable like
the idea of vulnerability is rolling an
animal rolling over and showing its
belly it can get hurt
you put that on the table and he looks
at you and says I'm not talking to you
about this
which could happen it's a risk
um then you have
bigger issues and my gut tells me you
know you have bigger issues
this is not indicative of a healthy
marriage and usually people are not
unhealthy in one place
usually if you get the flu your whole
body hurts and you throw up and you got
the rockets and you've you're you know
all you feel your head hurts all of you
hurt
my guess is this is just a small piece
of a larger relationship issue that you
need to deal with okay
um George what do you think I I just
don't know what to believe about this
guy like there's he's saying they're
dead free with no mortgage she has no
idea because she's not involved in any
of the finances he's got bit she doesn't
even know what kind of business ventures
he's into and so this all seems like
it's built on a House of Lies and while
she may be in a great place financially
merrily this is a terrible situation and
I I'm gonna go with maybe maybe he tells
you you're out of debt you don't know he
uh tells you that uh
something happens he goes I had no idea
he had four different credit cards and a
different account that I had no and he
racked up all this debt and now he's
disappeared or he's passed away and then
you're left while grieving with this
whole financial picture to deal with
going I don't know the login to the bank
account right and let's make no mistake
you are not a Dave Ramsey guy if your
wife does not have a sequel I mean an
equal if not more powerful seat at the
table it was a bonus chapter of Total
Money Makeover where Dave said don't
talk about money with your spouse make
sure to keep all accounts separate
secret yeah no this is not part of the
plan we don't even know if her name is
on the bank account that's right or on
the mortgage if you have ever had the
opportunity to sit at the table with
Dave and Sharon
you would know that Laura and your
husband is not a Dave Ramsey guy because
Sharon knows everything and please tell
him to stop self-proclaiming that that's
embarrassing it's embarrassing to all of
us yeah he paid off his credit cards
great good job man paid off his mortgage
maybe good do the next hard thing which
is sit down with your wife and explain
where all the money is how it works and
stop using I know something you don't
know as a as a tool of power it's the
weakest form of leadership is I know
something you don't know it's the worst
all right let's go to Linda in Orlando
Florida what's up Linda
Hi how are you
um I'm great
I I wanted to know okay
I'm jumping I I don't know if you want
to ask me something no come on in what's
up okay okay is it okay to bargain with
a debt collector on a hospital bill when
the hospital refused to provide an
itemized bill
well yeah yes it's always okay to
bargain with collection companies
I'm concerned that they wouldn't give
you a bill why wouldn't they give you an
itemized bill
uh-huh
okay and they just sent it to
collections it was through the ER we
went to the ER with my husband
um last year
and they
had done an extra x-ray
and a covet test and said it was covered
and sent us home saying that they
couldn't treat us okay and then they
sent a fifteen hundred dollar bill
and I said well I need an itemized bill
and they said okay we'll get back to you
they sent the same bill
nothing itemized and I asked them again
for an itemized build and then they sent
it to collections okay so here's my
guess well actually this I don't even
want to guess have you driven up to the
hospital and say I need a bill
because now I'm being sued by
collections on something that I've never
gotten itemized bill for
no I haven't done that okay this is one
foul if I told you hey there's one
thousand five hundred dollars over at
the hospital in an envelope and you just
go pick it up you would stop what you're
doing and go pick that up
and often I've been there too I just
wait for emails or I just make phone
calls and I don't actually get in there
and not disrespectfully not ugly but
cause a Ruckus and say hey you're
billing me 1 500 maybe I do owe that
money and I'll pay it but I need to know
what I'm paying
that's not unreasonable but you need to
look somebody in the eye and say please
while I'm here print me off a bill
because I asked for it twice and now
you're now another company is suing me
for it and it's not fair because I'm
just waiting on you guys okay and it's
best if you could even take in
um take in the dates that you made the
phone calls
um I called on this day I called on this
day here's a copy of my phone records
I've been waiting for this really not
cool that y'all rolled this thing over
already on me please give me an
opportunity to see what you're even
charging me right and then yes when a
collection company calls absolutely you
can negotiate with them and never give
them any personal information never give
them access to your bank account you can
do a cashier's check money order when
the time comes if they do choose to
settle they say we'll take a thousand
dollars and I mean you can hassle the
collections company and say listen you
show me the itemized bill and I'll be
happy to pay but until then I don't know
what this is and what I'm even paying
for and it could turn out to be a bad
debt and they just clear it and it could
turn out that
um you paid 118 dollars for a piece of
tape and you can sit down with the
hospital and protest that but they've
never Tylenol right they've never been
me the opportunity to do that or a 750
covet whatever the thing who knows
um
but yeah they get it in writing whatever
they say you make sure to get it in
writing so that you don't call back and
say whoa I paid in full and they go I
don't know where you got that from
that's exactly right so just some good
steps I I was stunned I didn't ever
think this through I shouldn't say I'm
stunned I was surprised I didn't know
this this sort of practice would be
legal but um our friend Anthony O'Neill
used to work for a collection agency for
a season
um and the gold standard was to get like
I'll cut a deal with you right now I'll
take a thousand dollars off but I'm
gonna direct deposit it I mean I'm gonna
direct withdrawal from your checking
account you gotta if you give me your
checking account number I'm gonna get
this thing done right now and I'll do
500 over the next seven months and
people were so desperate they'd say okay
great I got a payment plan and man that
money would start the account draining
that count that's right so don't ever
give your checking account number your
credit card number anything like that
always get it in writing
um and get a cashier's check from your
bank it's worth three or five bucks or
whatever it costs to get that done thank
you so much for the call Linda triple
eight eight two five 5225 this is the
Ramsay show give us a shout we'll be
right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
and Ryan Lander Wisconsin what's up Alan
how we doing man
I'm doing the best I can and my wife and
I
I my wife and I are 36 years old we are
a family of five blended family
um
and our oldest is 12.
um
we split 50 50 custody and we had two
other kids of seven and four
and uh like I said we are dealing with
our oldest 12 year old I was about six
weeks ago threatened to take his life
and thankfully told my wife and I on the
phone to
and we've been taking him to therapy
once a week
and just kind of seeking your advice
what else we should do in our situation
thank you
um I'm so sorry man
was that out of the blue
been struggling for a while
uh with because we are 50 50 split with
his father and coming to our house
that's
a good chunk of it besides at school he
said of bullying
um
and it just puts a lot of stress with
that what's the relationship like with
bio dad
uh it's for the most part good okay um
or let me ask it this way after
um I'm assuming after your 12 year old
said he's thinking about
um dime by Suicide you got him into the
mental health care that he needed that's
a moment and if it hasn't happened yet
this this is Step number one that all
the adults get in a room I don't care
what happened in the past I don't care
any of that stuff if everybody is gonna
act like an adult they need to get in a
room
because now this is this is different
than I get this and I get that stuff's
got to be put on the back burner because
we got a young a young kid here who's
crying out for help
yes we're just thankful that we're
my wife and him are a little bit closer
than his dad and uh always communicate
regularly
whether he's especially with us at home
but when he's with his dad make sure
everything's okay and we're just
thankful that he didn't hold uh
something in uh taking his life a little
bit too much longer and uh so we could
help the best that we could how's
counseling going
so far it's so good
um
it's helped him uh to speak out with the
therapist and uh you sound like you're
struggling
yeah as a stepfather of trying to make
sure that he's okay and
and we're trying to co-parent with his
father and let me go back to what I said
have you and that and his father and
your wife and his father's wife or
girlfriend whoever have you all gotten
in a room and said we have to work
together on what comes next
yeah my wife and his father Yes that the
three of us are communicating on the
phone together okay yes okay all right
good
um
The Next Step here so you got your kid
in counseling which is great the next
thing I want you to look at is the
environment of your home
where are the other where are other
things on fire in your house stress wise
how's your marriage how are your other
kids are D are you struggling
financially
um do you have addiction issue like
where is other tension here's what I
always want to look at with kids kids
absorb tension
they absorb the people always say like I
got I got my parents got divorced when I
was seven and my first thought is yeah
but you lived through their relationship
from age four to seven right so that
trauma is two three four five years old
um if not more where where are other
tension points in your home right now
well the paycheck the paycheck I worked
overnights and my wife was a
stay-at-home mother to try to save on
daycare and now she recently right here
four weeks ago began
um back to work okay uh helped me out
and I have since got a day shift job to
be at home at night to help with getting
all the kids
at home taken care of and with the
oldest situation to be there as well so
is that hurting you financially is that
helping you financially what's the what
is the status paycheck to paychecks a
lot of stress in your home
we're about the same if not a little bit
further behind Okay uh since then she's
kind of replaced my second job income
but
so here's what I want you to do what do
you do for a living
I work in a meat processing plant okay
I want you to that was a great move on
her part she can get a discount
um I want you to think about what life
looks like Alan in 24 months
two years
36 months 48 months
and I want you to be honest with
yourself about your financial reality
with what you have found yourself
and I rely
exclusively on a great butcher who helps
me and my family out
and you might have found yourself in a
profession that you love that simply is
not tenable anymore because you can't
eat
or you can't breathe
because it doesn't make enough money
and you can't keep working 20-hour days
with multiple kids and like I mean you
did the right thing coming home
but I want you to begin thinking long
term now
paycheck to paycheck cause causes
poverty causes us fear about money
caused us to get laser focused on the
next minute and the next minute we start
to lose the bigger picture and you blink
and you're 49 years old working the same
job with the same problems
see what I'm saying
yes and so I want you to give yourself
some space whether that's I'm going to
take an afternoon off and I know I can't
afford it we're going to figure it out
and either you go talk to somebody
or you get one or two people in your
life that are 10 years ahead of you that
you trust and you say okay I'm gonna
have to make an adjustment because I'm
just trying to do the same thing over
and over and over again and I'm getting
further and further behind
and I would say this is a a work
conversation and I'm going to send you a
copy of Ken Coleman's book paycheck to
purpose and send you a copy of his
um his his get clear assessment on other
jobs you might have but I don't know
that this is a work issue right now
this is a I'm exhausted I'm married into
this this is not what the picture of my
life I drew up I'm just worn out
that's what this sounds like am I right
uh not fully it's just I I know
sometimes the Lord tests the strong and
everything kind of just hit us all at
once you know since February with my
mother-in-law's going to the hospital
and then I missed a week of work and
then fell behind
um taking out a little bit more low ones
and trying to just stay afloat and then
with that and Alan you're not listening
to me brother you've got no margin right
no
and as hard as this is to say she will
go back to the hospital at some point
my mom and dad will too
I was at a funeral for a family member
two days ago it happens suddenly
there will be challenges
and so your goal the reason we tell
people this idea of Peace this idea of
being able to go to sleep
is not going to keep mom from getting
cancer Financial Peace is not going to
keep kids from getting bullied at school
but it's going to give us some margin to
deal with those things when they happen
that's what we're talking about
um you are in desperate need of Peace of
margin so that you can take a week off
to be with your mother-in-law in the
hospital and your family doesn't have to
decide do we eat or keep the heater on
that's what we're talking about and
that's going to require you to get back
and say whoa what comes next hang on the
line I'm also going to send you a copy
of Total Money Makeover and own your
past change your future it's three books
that I want you to read spend some time
and start thinking
how do we survive this right now you're
doing a great job got your kid in
counseling you and your wife probably
need to go see somebody not probably
they do and then you have to start
asking yourself what are we going to do
in two years
and you've got a reverse engineer and
start planning
you my brother are worth a life of peace
it's another hour in the books here on
the Ramsey Show we'll be back shortly
stay with us
[Music]
do you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsey show where death is dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice
here on on the Ramsay show America hangs
out to have a conversation about your
money your life and I'm stumbling for
the intro here George you're just so
nervous to be co-hosting with me John it
happens to the best of us it's hard to
sit in The Shadow of Your Excellence
it's such a small Shadow it's such a
it's amazing that is true I should stand
up it's impressive on its own right I'm
John deloney joined by George Campbell
and we're taking your calls Triple eight
eight two five five two two five and I
hope to not stumble through your calls
let's go to Liz in Mobile Alabama what's
up Elizabeth
hi John it's so good to talk to you
again it's supposed to be about a year
ago
on a much different place in life now so
I'm happy to report that but I've got a
question for you well tell me about your
journey
about it Liz give me the spark notes
um about a year ago I was at a place
where I was uh escaping domestic
violence with my five children who had
nowhere to go had no income had been a
stay-at-home mother for 15 years
um was living in a camper in my friend's
backyard yes I remember you list okay
yeah thanks for calling back where are
you now
hey um well you know the kids and I are
healthy and well I am a full-time
student I'm going into nursing wow I
quickly found out that you know there's
no entry-level job that you can get that
really supports the family this large
right
um so I'm I'm going after my dreams that
I abandoned all those years ago Liz I'm
so proud of you what a gift for you your
community those people you're going to
serve and for your kids
you are you are a real life no hold on
you're a real life model
of what it looks like to get knocked
down and get back up you're you can we
we teach our kids that we read them
children's books and we talk about it
your kids are going to have a picture of
it
I hope so incredible that's my greatest
hope good for you all right so how can
we help you today you know nothing
that's not for a God who goes before me
because I tell you he's been there every
step of the way
you know through no doing of my own his
people and his hand have just been all
over our lives it's it's just been a
miracle but um awesome the big money
question that I'm looking at right now
is I'm still in a place where my income
is less than my outcome okay uh as less
than you know I'm making far less than
what I'm spending and luckily I do have
a substantial savings uh right now as it
were but I drive a very large vehicle
um with the kids and I
um it gets terrible gas mileage I've
been looking into getting a second
vehicle
um because the what I'm doing for work
now is delivering
um you know either packages or you know
food delivery things like this that I
can do outside of school hours
it provides me the flexibility and
schedule and things come up with the
kids so it's a good couple of hustles to
have
um so I like having
I like having you know it's a big band
for for when we need to go places I need
to have all the kids with me or or what
have you but it's so bad on mileage that
I'm considering dropping three or four
thousand into
a decent uh like reliable smaller
vehicle for when I don't need to have
all the people with me and that can
still give me
the availability to
you know haul all the packages I need to
do my job but also efficient daily
driver
could you split the difference could you
sell the bigger car get a smaller one
that still fits the kids
that's
um
the issue is uh
not
I
I feel like if we got something
smaller and got entirely rid of the
largest vehicle it would be difficult I
happen to have really uh
you know my older two are are quite tall
now it's it's not super feasible to get
everybody into you know like how tall
are these kids I'm just I'm genuinely
curious as a small guy uh my two
teenagers are you know six feet and six
two
represent yeah those are giants sitting
next to Georgia I wouldn't yes my worry
partially is what happens when both cars
need repairs and now you're paying
Insurance on two cars and what you
thought was going to be a benefit is now
more of an expense that's what buying
three thousand dollars or four thousand
dollars okay let's say you did the math
on here's what the gas mileage is here's
what I would say if here's that Gap
um I could actually make more money if I
had a three or four thousand dollar car
great that math is fine George just
brought up a great point you have to
bring in the math of the extra insurance
and the extra that's another oil change
another set of tires another set of all
those things build up and up and up and
up so at one point I had an old truck
that I was gonna rebuild
um with me and my son disaster I don't
know if you've we've never met but I'm
not a I'm not a Rebuilder and I kept my
wife's Corolla as just a paid off car
that we had in the driveway that could
be my daily driver and then I after
paying the registration the oil change I
realized my free car was costing me a
big chunk of money every month
annualized over the course of a year and
I realized oh this isn't so free at all
right so I ended up getting I ended up
selling it
um because it it never made its money
back on the gas how close are your kids
to driving
that's the other consideration I was
going to bring up we're we're months
away so
um
on a you know on a 12 passenger van is
not ideal you know you don't want to
wear a loaf of bread no it's fantastic
are they saving for a car
oh yeah I'd love to take in parallel
parking I'd be right yeah hey you don't
have to worry about them dating that's
going to be fantastic well you know with
a given a kid a van can go the other way
too oh there you go you know you don't
want to turn a teenager loose my first
car was driving Mom and Dad's minivan
it's awesome well well well played Liz
well played so I'm I'm just wondering
can the kids save up and maybe you match
them and you get a car and maybe you can
use it for your side hustle and you know
until they're they're fully driving and
out of the house a little bit is that a
possibility have they been saving up for
a car
what he has been saving up a little bit
you know I mean is that in school
full-time playing sports at a you know
as private school as well which is
another oh boy that's the real expense
in your life it's private school yes
absolutely yep uh faith-based private
school so we're just you know it's
everywhere I'm just so thankful but um
he
has you know he's not able to work a
whole lot he does his own business he
does uh lawn care and odd jobs and
things oh great so he can save up three
grand over a year
yeah possibly I mean I would certainly
expect him to You Know cover Insurance
you know gas if he's driving full-time I
think that would be
a
fair
um expectation if I were to purchase the
second vehicle okay um what are you
doing with school either way
uh it's gonna be about two years okay
maybe a little maybe a semester left
like you know three four more semesters
cool well this is all temporary so I
would find a temporary solution and that
might mean you buy a beater car and you
give it to the kid later on he buys it
from you but the A1 is getting to a
financial place and uh that worries me
to have all of these extra expenses I
would probably just keep the van and let
that and every time I fill it up at
night I would let it inspire me to keep
grinding and get out of this mess but
that's just me we'll be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five I'm
John deloney joined here by George
Campbell and we are taking your calls on
life money work mental health
relationships all of it triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go to Nick in Atlanta Georgia what's up
Nick how we doing
good how are you outstanding my man
what's up
hey so I'm 23 years old and I'm sure
this cut this copy has been covered
before but I was just looking for
insight on you know moving out of your
parents house and you know which one is
more important kind of you know saving
up for next day just because it'll be my
first you know Venture
um in a you know expensive apartment or
would it be you know paying off debt
very cool man so um
you have a job
I do yes I um I made fifty thousand
fantastic man what are you doing
I'll look at Enterprise the car rental
business yeah good for you man cool cool
and what is now causing you at 23 to go
all right I've had enough I'm moving out
oh nothing major you know it's really
good here it's just you know I kind of
what that independent thing you know
creating something for myself
very cool and you're in Atlanta proper
I am and what is rent right now in the
areas you would want to live in
it's looking like around that 15 to 1700
ranch or somewhere you know not even
just uh luxury but you know safe
outwards because you know a man is kind
of used just a different type of City so
I would say you know somewhere safe than
uh prosperous about 15 to 1700 and what
is your take-home pay every month what
ends up in your bank account
about three thousand dollars after cases
and so we're talking about over 50 of
your income going towards rent
if you move out today
yes is that not frighten you
it does that's why it's just like that's
why he's calling us George well I'm
trying to just open up some options here
could you get a roommate
I could that could work I'm going to
rephrase that you have to get a roommate
I'm sorry I didn't mean it as an option
this is part of so my here's my thing
you talked about independence and the
truth is right now we can't afford full
Independence we're going to have someone
else living with us regardless
sure and so the question is do you want
it to be a stranger or your family I get
it you want to get out you want to feel
like I'm a grown man you know leaving
the nest and I love that but you're
gonna have to get a roommate in order to
afford living where you want to live
yes I mean that's that's the bad thing
about living in Georgia so that that's
part of it that's something to Grapple
with is you're going to have to vet and
find a reliable safe trustworthy
roommate who pays on time you get along
with at some level so that's part of the
picture the other one is all of the
other expenses that come along with that
you're going to need to get renters
insurance you are now not able to eat
dinner at your parents house every day
so you're going to have to learn how to
cook because going out to eat every day
is going to make you broke and we're not
going out to eat because we got some
debt to pay off is that right
very true okay how much debt
about 50 Grand in total between schools
and credit cards
what are you doing
what was your degree in
I got it in sociology
oh Nick if we could turn back time Nick
If I Could Turn Back Time We Sing or
else we cry that's right so Nick I I if
I'm you well let me just tell you I'm
just gonna be honest I've never told the
story publicly George
um nervous and excited at 21
I was at my parents house after
graduating college
um and I had a chance encounter with an
old uh track coach I ended up taking a
job as a high school teacher and coach
in the Houston area and I lived I was
gonna live with my parents for a while
and pay off my student loans within a
month my dad was like hey man what if I
paid your first month's rent and I was
like I'm already out of here and if I
had to do that all over I would have
stayed there until I was debt free
yes very true by me taking not taking
two years to take care of my business I
went and bought the biggest stupid truck
I could I went and got a nice apartment
I I just lived beyond my means and
um
uh I wouldn't recommend doing that I
wouldn't I wouldn't run out of my mom
and dad's house until I was debt free
what are your monthly payments Nick
between the student loans and the credit
card
probably about uh 300 bucks that's it
no no it feels way too low for fifty
thousand dollars worth of debt
that's why Mr Pam I had to start paying
my um all my student loans
basically what I'm hearing is life
hasn't actually happened yet yeah life's
about to hit you in the mouth dude when
those student loans get unpaused it's
going to be a harsh reality my friend
I'm so glad you called us because you
were about to go sign a 1700 a month
lease for 12 months for 12 months and
then you're gonna start paying back
street loans you're gonna realize you
have 11 left over after just expenses
and then you're gonna have to break the
lease pay the fees and then move back in
with mom and dad with your head hung low
so I'm not I'm not in the boat of like
you have to pay off all the debt before
you leave the house but I do think we
have to think long and hard about how
we're going to do this and maybe it's an
exit strategy of hey I'm gonna pay off
as much debt as I can aggressively I'm
working overtime and a year from now I'm
gonna move out and then I'm gonna get a
roommate and I'm still going to work
overtime and I'm still not going to be
eating out because I want this debt gone
very true that's the goal and so I love
that you want to be independent I think
that's a great thing it's going to do a
lot for your dignity uh and for your
spirit but right now it's going to be a
burden and a curse if you just jump ship
today
yeah it's true so make a plan here's the
deal we're going to send you Financial
Peace University okay
um is your is your graduation gift we're
going to send you send you every dollar
app too so you can begin tracking your
money you can practice making a budget
and maybe get your parents to watch
these videos too with you
um get some buddies together and watch
them
um and we want you to watch all these
things we're going to send them to you
okay I'm gonna give you a year of the
apps you can start tracking your money I
want you to begin to live in or own or
acknowledge whatever word you want to
use you've got to live in reality
and you want to be independent you want
to jump off I do I'm all in I've been
there I totally get it and you simply
have put yourself in a financial
position where you can't afford to do
that yet responsibly you could if you
had to
um you'd end up in a in a part of the
community like you mentioned that you
don't want to live in or you're going to
have to have two or three roommates and
you find yourself man I wish I just had
mom here at least she cooked dinner and
did my laundry so my roommates don't
even do the dishes yeah it's the it's
the inverse it's disgusting they let
things soak instead of putting them in
the dishwasher I had roommates up until
just about up until I was married I did
absolutely a part of a financial reality
we know we live in a very wealthy County
and so to live anywhere near here you're
looking at you know 12 it used to be 800
900 bucks for a two bedroom in the
general Nashville area that's 100
million dollars now it's yes 4 billion
and that gets you a it's like a New York
studio apartment it's exactly so it's
just part of the reality is I don't want
to do this but I got to get a roommate
because I have financial goals and I
can't meet those goals if I have all
this debt hanging over my head and my
payment is Jack gigantic so here's a
common thing when people have to face
reality
I didn't mean Dave and I've talked about
I didn't mean to put on 40 pounds during
covet it happened right here's where
here's this is reality I didn't mean to
look up and sell them a hundred thousand
dollars
it happened I didn't mean to wait I've
gone three weeks and me and my wife
haven't had a meaningful conversation or
I snapped at my kids there's something
about not looking to blame not looking
to run out and be like well let's speak
just exhaling and looking in the mirror
and saying you know what this time this
one's on me yes I did what I was told
yes my parents told me to go to college
and take out big student loans yes I
just was told after college you don't
you're not coming back to this house and
so I went and got an apart
I did it I signed my name on that line I
listened to bad information I did the
best I could with what I had but here's
where I'm at this is my reality because
only then
can you ask yourself that scary
terrifying question of what am I gonna
do now yeah right and there's a season
for most of us of grief I didn't mean
for this to happen I didn't know this
was going to happen I didn't understand
what this was going to feel like when I
got here with a golly I mean can you
imagine Nick is millions and millions
and millions of us yeah right who man
I'm making 50 000 bucks I'm making great
money especially for my first job I
didn't make fifty thousand dollars or 23
right and surely I can get an apartment
and a car and food and go hang out with
my friends and go to concerts nope as
part of the narrative that's how you owe
50 Grand in student loans and you have a
car loan and you got credit card I mean
you can't wait till I'm an adult and I
can live on my own and then you realize
I can't afford to do any of this or I'm
gonna eat Taco Bell every meal and then
your digestive system has a stick right
we think this is gonna be this way it's
just not you gotta own reality and you
gotta grieve it like I didn't mean for
it too then you got to say okay what do
we do next right and that's where the
financial peace is so great absolutely
so hang on the line Nick we're going to
make sure to get you Financial Peace
University and every dollar get you on a
plan I can't wait for you to call back
two years from now and be like I'm
completely debt free living on my own we
did it I did it
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five I'm
John deloney joined here by George camel
listen right now is the time of the year
when it's make or break when it comes to
our goals we're heading into holiday
season
and I don't care who you are it's hard
to stay motivated when it gets cold and
it's dark in the morning it's just hard
to get up and get going we all have
goals whether it's to find a better job
make more money pay off debt build
stronger relationships and it can be
hard to get momentum going and to keep
it going but here's the good news coming
up in a couple of weeks we have one of
our biggest events smart conference
we're headed to Dallas for a day-long
jam-packed event where you'll get advice
from leading experts on money personal
growth career mental health and your
marriage you'll leave with all the
knowledge and motivation you need to
reach your goals and live the life you
want join Dave Ramsey and the rest of
the Ramsay personalities including me
Ken Coleman Christina Ellis Rachel Cruz
even
George Campbell appreciate the invite
George Campbell got invited
um and we're also going to have uh Craig
Rochelle and his wife it's a bunch of
people it's gonna be a blast kind of
live music it's going to be an all-day
event join us live in person on October
22nd to get your passes before they sell
out and it will sell out
visit ramseysolutions.com events to get
your tickets today very very cool be a
fun one I'm looking forward to it we're
gonna audition to try to be in it we'll
see if they'll have us I think it's
going to be no chance okay no chance all
right let's go to RJ and spoken
Washington what's up RJ
hi thanks for taking my call what's up
I have a question so my husband and I
are about 60 years old and due to the
circumstances with or some circumstances
with covid we had to shut down our
business and retire five years earlier
than expected
so in the meantime we have no income for
the next five years until we can draw
Social Security and I am looking for
guidance or advice on ways that we can
make our the money we do have last
you know until we're 85 90 years old can
I ask you a hard question RJ
sure
um so this is I want you to picture me
and you having some nachos me you and
George sitting at the tables hanging out
okay this isn't me like pointing my
finger at you okay
okay you you and your husband
um had to close your business
but you did not have to retire early
and you may have had five years of doing
jobs that you hated or didn't like
um I was with my mom this weekend and
she she called a few about a year and a
half ago and said hey I'm thinking about
retiring and my first question was can
you afford to retire
and
that sounds like a question y'all didn't
ask yourselves it sounds like you just
jumped and retired early why'd you do
that
well we
we couldn't find workers and so we were
in an accident like 10 years ago and my
husband
um really is no longer too he was a very
hard worker and he just is no longer to
be out on the job site okay
um I watched my grandkids which is no I
mean I could go get a job but
I've raised my kids now I'm just kind of
watching my grandkids and
um
yeah I could we could get a job I guess
um making minimum wage yeah yeah um why
would you why would you say that about
yourself
well I'm old we're old I don't care this
is one of the hottest job markets the
hottest job market ever ever I just
talked to a 58 year old he was making
130 Grand working an I.T
there's no such thing as well I'm 60 so
I have to do minimum wage jobs
you have amazing experience
we by all of that and we couldn't find
workers you know I mean but that was
that was a couldn't several years ago
and now we're here right now
and let's look at it this way you had a
season of we had we have to shut this
thing down nobody will work or nobody
can work the city shut down we can't
afford payroll we can't afford to keep
our our business going we're closing the
business
honey you can't get up and grind it like
you used to you put in like 30 40 50 60
years of grinding it out for the family
we can't do that anymore okay so here we
are
um you really want to raise your kids
and then raise those grandkids
and I want to give my kids relief right
now the reality is if y'all run out of
money at 87 your kids are going to pay
that bill
Fair yeah yeah and so I think the
greatest gift you could give your kids
is to say hey we can't afford to do what
we're doing right now we have found
ourselves in an unsustainable we're
looking at the numbers down the road
this is unsustainable we're gonna have
to do something different
and I want you to set your goals way
higher than minimum wage
you've got incredible value to offer
and I have no idea even what your job
was what you can do I know though you've
got too much experience to just walk in
and say well lowly me nobody wants me no
way you you already keep kids you can
open a daycare in your home and make a
jillion dollars because we paid child
care before they basically print money
right I don't know I don't know what
what your skill set is I don't know what
you want to do
um but that's my first that's my first
initial question
um is okay why have you just said this
is the way this has to be for five years
and how do we stretch this and do this
and oh no that's gonna work it sounds
like you have a picture of the life that
you want
and you're trying to make math that
doesn't work fit that picture and you're
going to make yourself bananas and
you're going to find yourself broke at
85 years old
oh well but I'm hoping
hoping what you have
well so I won't see that scenario that'd
be great so what do you got yeah
watch what she's gonna say I've got 11
million dollars
but but I want you to know we were
married young we have been very poor so
we we've worked hard for what we have so
we live brutally you know I mean we we
don't drive big fancy cars or anything
like that so but this is what we do have
so
um we have about five hundred thousand
dollars invested we have about three
hundred thousand dollars in checking
savings account
um our house is worth about eight
hundred thousand dollars and we have
probably a little over but right about a
million dollars in land and real estate
that we've
acquired over the year which every year
can rise or lower you know you just
don't know but but right now it's that
and then we have about two hundred
thousand dollars
um kind of stashed away in cash that my
husband does like physical on hand so
physical because they call okay yeah
okay so you have a couple million
dollars RJ lead with that
with that what's the 500k invested in
you know it's it's with an investor that
um I I know it goes by the S P 500 oh
it's not retirement
is it just an index fund it kind of is
there's no kind of either it's a
retirement account or it's a
non-retirement account
no it is a it's a retirement account
because when we're 65 it will pay us
money oh no you know is this an annuity
Dave Ramsey and
that sounds and it should not be an idea
I can't remember what it it actually is
called but we we our annuity is a
contract with an insurance company and
then it pays you a fixed income later on
in life it's that it's that's what it
sounds like you're describing so no no
smartvestor from our company would
recommend that
okay so the home is paid for the 800 000
home
it is oh wonderful although I do have a
another question on that down the road
but everything is paid for we we owe
nothing we have we have no bills
um and you guys are gonna be fine you're
fine now how old are you RJ
sorry Georgia okay
so if you worked with a smartvestor pro
and you said Hey listen I wanna we wanna
have this much this kind of Lifestyle we
want to pull I don't know 80k a year
let's say then we would go all right
well you know we do 25 times 80. and
that would kind of give you your magic
number
um to tell you this is kind of what
you're looking at if you want to pull 80
000 a year you need two million dollars
in that account to withdraw from at
about a four percent rate so that it can
continue to grow that's called the
Trinity rule
and so I would probably I would consider
maybe selling this land in real estate
if it hasn't been doing that great and
you can get a million dollars and go
ahead and invest that and invest this
200 000 in cash that is just burning a
hole in the ground and can't keep up
with inflation but then a high yield
savings account even and make two and a
half percent on it so I just don't want
you sitting on the sidelines because
you're fearful of are you gonna have
enough money in retirement so get in
touch with a different smart investor
Pro I don't know who you're working with
and get a second opinion on all this
money and all these numbers so that it
can work for you and let's get a let's
get a map a direction here's where we're
going here's how much money we need to
get and here's what it's going to take
to get there and let's don't work in
clouds and Fantasies okay let's get some
real numbers
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
scripture of the day is from Leviticus 1
14. but if his offering to the Lord is a
burnt offering of birds then he shall
bring his offering from the turtle doves
or from Young doves
I don't know what that means
Jace Robertson from Duck Dynasty says
doves are the filet mignon of the sky
that is a great quote
it's a lot of doves so many doves a lot
of doves a lot of are they trolling you
I think I'm getting you okay I think I
just got it's dove season I think I just
got trolled
with some old school Leviticus well done
leave it to Leviticus to roast you leave
it to Jase Robertson all right let's go
to uh
let's go to Miche in Birmingham what's
up Michelle
nothing much how are y'all excellent how
are you
I am surviving a cold but a quick
question for you good we'll get better
soon
what's up
can I make contributing to my HSA a part
of my 15 going to retirement
it's not a part of the 15 I want you to
contribute to that but it wouldn't be
considered retirement because it can
only be used towards you know qualified
Health expenses and it can't put food on
the table it can't really do much other
than cover some health care
gotcha and so I would invest 15 are you
in baby step four
are you out of debt completely and have
a fully funded emergency fund
yes I do have that okay great so beyond
the 15 if you want to contribute to your
HSA it's a great investing vehicle
because the money goes in tax-free grows
tax free you can withdraw a tax-free
towards those qualified Health expenses
and you can put as much in there you
know there's there's some limits but you
know past about a thousand dollars in
our at least in ours you can invest that
money and so it can actually grow for
you tax free as part of an overarching
retirement plan but it's not part of the
actual 15 percent
oh okay awesome yeah great question I
have enough sounds like you're crushing
it yeah way to go even with the cold
yeah awesome they get better thank you
so much hope you feel better soon let's
go to almir in Minneapolis
Minneapolis I always say that wrong
every time what's up Amir
hey can you guys hear me okay absolutely
what's up man
that's all my questions about your
guys's credit cards I know you guys are
um not for credit cards and I understand
speak a little more clearly for us elmir
talk into the microphone can you hear
him perfect yep
um so I know you guys are against credit
cards and I understand why but I simply
figured out a system but for me I have
all of our recurring bills that we have
to pay for every month whether it's Thai
the daycare electric gas set on a credit
card which saves in a safe account and
then every month when my credit card
payment is due which I'd pay anyways I
pay it off every month and I would get
50 sometimes 100 100 in reward points
every month
is there a negative to that or is it
positive I use that fifteen hundred
dollars to reinvest in some certain
ETFs or stocks on Robinhood
well I don't know what plan you've been
following but it's not the Ramsay plan
and that's fine it sounds like you're on
you're doing great financially you're
out of debt completely you've got a
fully funded emergency fund
yeah I'm at a close on emergency Farm I
have 15 need between our household
income put away I'm on a 20-year loan
for a 20-year term for a mortgage
um so I'm doing all the steps I and I
know that's the one big step there's no
credit cards but I just found that
something that worked I implemented a
few years and I'm Building Wealth out of
it sure well we would never tell you to
invest in single stocks and I did a
whole episode on the Robinhood app on my
podcast to find print so if you want to
learn more about that you can check that
out but the the credit card dilemma that
you're bringing up is one that we get a
lot and everyone that brings it up is
going listen I get it people can't
control their spending but I have
mastered it I have figured it out I
never spent a dime on interest I get my
cash back I am winning I'm beating the
system
and at the end of the day uh it's not
moments like that where you lose it's
the moments where life doesn't go
exactly according to plan and now all of
a sudden we have to put those on the
credit card because we had an emergency
that exceeded our income and we don't
know what to do now and life kept
punching Us in the face and we went well
at least we're still getting the Cash
Back Rewards and so truthfully I think
you can do a lot better just spending
with a debit card when you use your own
money and I understand you're putting
recurring bills that you normally would
spend on right
but psychologically we make different
decisions number one with other people's
money and number two with that kind of
reward level thinking
and Amir I'm I'm was in your exact shoes
okay I had recurring bills put on a
credit card that got me free fly points
and I never was going to be in debt
again I paid it off every month and all
was good
let me tell you why I quit okay and I I
don't think any of the rules apply to me
and I always think I'm the exception
right
um so I'm like you I'm never gonna have
a problem I've got an emergency fund I'm
not worried about ever going into debt
again I'm just I'm just going to take
their free money here's why I quit
I was beating that system if you will I
was playing their game and I was doing
fine
you are too
but somebody's paying that fifteen
hundred dollars a month that you take
home and you know who it is it's a
single mom with four kids that can't eat
and she's paying for your Robinhood
account
it was the guy who just got fired and
couldn't buy groceries and so he had to
put on a credit card that was the dude
who was paying for my flights at 30
percent
and I couldn't stomach taking a free
flight
off the backs of some of of people who
had hit rock bottom or people who had
legitimate issues psychologically with
controlling their spending or whatever
I didn't want I opted out of that system
because it's disgusting and I don't want
that free flight I'll pay for my own
flights I'll figure it out
does that make sense that's why I opted
out of it man the whole system is so
predatory off those who are struggling
who don't know any better or who are
don't or found themselves in a mess
where their rent just doubled and they
live in a city they can't afford and
they can't get a new job on in one day
well I've got you I got you covered at
30 at 28 and if you miss a payment it
goes to 40 and by the way you can never
borrow I'm just out of that system man
because somebody else is paying for my
flights that's why I got out yeah I'm
I'm curious almir how much are you
spending a month to get 50 bucks back
so here's I have a two two-way system
one of my system so I started this a few
years ago and I I think the biggest
thing is discipline I'm a very
disciplined person I mean I'm an
immigrant as well I see my parents in
debt and I see what credit cards can do
I train myself to never be again I never
will
um but I've like I said I remember
recurring bills that uh that get charged
like my tide my daycare all these things
will get charged in my account then I do
the Dave Ramsey envelopes and then in
one of my envelope systems one that one
the envelope says returns or credit card
payment so we have two credit cards one
of the smaller one so if we buy
groceries I'll put groceries on credit
card I'll transmit envelope to my shop
so I always it always balances you just
had to be different this is some fancy
footwork you're doing man and I my
parents are immigrants as well my dad is
from Egypt and I watched him do this
growing up and it's giving me PTSD to
hear about it because I know the anxiety
of oh my gosh we had to move the zero
percent APR to this card to get this
reward and it's Bonkers man so you do
you but man it's so much more peaceful
to do the Ramsay way yeah I'm opting out
of the system I'll I'll pay the the
peace tax is what I call it I'll lose
out on that 50 bucks to not have to deal
with it man
um but thank you so much for the call
almir
um hey real quick pods giveaway we know
a lot of you are planning on moving soon
and we got great news our new studio
sponsor PODS moving and storage wants to
help one of you move for free
just get a quote at pods.com Ramsey
between October 3rd and October 14th to
win right it's really that simple one
listener will get a free move or a free
storage rental that's up to a five
thousand dollar value look pause just
makes moving easier with the flexibility
you need the control you want and the
customer service you deserve if you're
looking for a company that will help you
move on your terms pods is the only
Ramsay trusted moving provider out there
so go to pods.com
Ramsay and enter to win a free moving or
Storage Rental today that's pods.com
Ramsay and dude I was just thinking when
I moved I would have loved this system I
didn't even know it existed man I'm so
it's incredible it's awesome great
company great leaders over there well
hey thanks George Campbell for
co-hosting the show I'd like to thank
all the guys in the booth and thank you
America for staying with us and and uh
hanging out with us be kind to one
another and we'll see you soon
foreign
[Music]
co-host of the Ramsey show did you know
over 18 million people listen to the
Ramsey show every week a lot of those
people listen on one of our 600 plus
radio stations across the country to
find a station near you go to
ramseysolutions.com show
foreign
[Music]